[Music]
you
[Music]
the free power of the content determines
itself in such a way that the dispersion
of the content into a sheer multiplicity
of personal atoms is by the nature of
this determinant is at the same time
gathered into a single point alien to
them and sold us as well the single
point is on the one hand like the
unyielding rigidity of their personality
a merely single personality but in
contrast to their empty singleness it
has at the same time the significance
for them of the whole content hence of
real essence and as against their
presumably absolute but intrinsic the
essence lists reality it is absolute
power and absolute actuality this Lord
and Master of the world holds himself in
this way to be the absolute person at
the same time embracing within himself
the whole of existence the person for
whom there exists no superior spirit in
the person but the solitary person who
stands over against all the rest
these constitute the real authoritative
universality of that person for the
single individual as such is is true
only as a universal multiplicity of
single individuals cut off from this
multiplicity the solitary self is in
fact an unreal impotent self at the same
time it is the consciousness of the
content which is placed itself in
antithesis to that Universal personality
but this content liberated from the
negative power controlling it is the
chaos of spiritual powers which in their
unfettered freedom become elemental
beings raging madly against one another
in a frenzy of destructive activity
their impotent self-consciousness as the
defense was enclosed arena their tumult
in this knowledge of himself as the sum
and substance of all actual powers this
lord and master of the world is the
titanic self-consciousness that thinks
of itself as being an actual living god
but since he is only the formal self
which is unable to tame those powers his
activities and self enjoyment are
equally monstrous excesses
in paragraph 481 and the two paragraphs
which follow Hegel is going to introduce
a new character to this great drama that
of the Lord of the world or its use
Miller's play a NASM the lord and master
of the world
it's actually their hair so so you know
Lord master these are both the same
thing but it's got kind of a nice ring
to it Lord and Master and why is he
bringing this up here it would be
tempting to simply plow ahead to get to
the end of this section looking at this
this you know figure that we've seen
popping up before we talked about death
as the absolute master back in the self
consciousness section we also saw
something sort of like this in the
unhappy consciousness portion of
self-consciousness which we're going to
see mentioned in just two paragraphs
from now but this is a bit different
this here we're talking about the world
of spirit we're talking about the way in
which the ethical substance played
itself out into a kind of catastrophe
succumb to an inevitable destiny this
Lord and Master of the world is one face
of that that destiny that fate that was
bringing to a close the interplay
between divine and human law and the
people who identified themselves with it
thereby trying to realize the the
ethical so what is Hegel describing here
he's talking about what individuality is
place is within this realm of legal
condition or legal right wrecks to stond
right and he's talking about something
like we can call a loss of determinate
meaning a loss that's taking place not
only on the part of the individual
persons who are not at the top level as
a matter of fact Hegel affirms that
there's nothing higher at this point
than that this this person who occupies
this spot but also a loss
of the fullness of meaning for that
person as well we can think of all sorts
of historical circumstances which might
you know very nicely tie in with this we
can think of many imaginary
circumstances as well and we can also
consider cases in our own framework our
own time our own culture going beyond
merely the political in to say
corporations or other institutions so
Hinkle goes on in this and he says the
free power of the content determines
itself in such a way what's the free
power of the content we've been talking
about skepticism and how that seemed
similar to what's going on in this
development of legal right in terms of
property right so the free content of
the free power this content determines
itself in such a way the dispersion of
the content into a sheer multiplicity of
personal atoms is by the nature of this
determinant is gathered into a single
point why should that be the case why
not just have a number of sort of
anarchic atoms bouncing off of each
other so long as there's some sort of
you know legal structure keeping them in
place something like a libertarian or
other utopian dream right well you need
some sort of enforcement power you need
something that functions like the
government in making sure that the legal
status is actually respected and here we
get to a particular Hobbesian
problematic don't we although it's one
that Plato is already posing back in the
Republic who will guard the Guardians
right who will keep track of them who
will oppose them and the answer in many
cases is nobody and Hegel is sketching
out for us cases where that is is the
situation so he goes on he says that
this single point is alien to these
right meaning that it's it's different
it's estranged from that
and soulless as well and here's where we
get to the really interesting part so
each of these persons we saw it in in
this this condition of legal right they
do what they're going to do they have
their individual life plans they have
their property and yet there's something
missing the the dialectic of recognition
has been sort of pushed aside that's
also not happening with this this person
as well so Hegel is going to sketch out
two things here in this section
occurring one is that this person comes
to the fore and what does that person do
how do they exist in relation to these
others but there's also a kind of
dependency of this person on the others
as well so he goes on and he says the
single point is on the one hand like the
unyielding rigidity of their personality
and merely single personality it could
be any one of these people elevated into
that position but at the same time in
contrast to their empty singleness it
has the same at the same time the
significance for them of the whole
content hence of real essence and
against their presumably absolute but in
intrinsically essence this reality he
says it is absolute power and actuality
so again let's think about this in terms
of property right because that provides
a useful peg to hang these flats on so
you know the the realm of legal right is
supposed to guarantee to everybody say
the protection of their property but who
who administers that who is the
executive it is this whatever occupies
this position of absolute power and
actuality and we could actually imagine
a whole set of layers right going you
know where we have subsidiary powers
deputies on the way there has to be
somebody to make this work and that is
this this Lord and Master
right the executive power
if you like and because of that they are
invested with absolute power there's
nobody else who can effectively resist
them there's David why does Hegel call
them actuality because they are in a
certain sense more actual than these
individual persons their will decides
and none of the Wills of these
individuals can actually resist them not
not as individuals so he goes on and he
calls this the lord and master of the
world and he says he is the absolute
person at the same time embracing within
himself a whole of existence notice the
next thing that he says the person for
whom there exists no superior spirit and
this is where it gets really interesting
there is no superior mind over above
this determining it so it sounds as if
ok this person has truly made it but at
the same time there's something lacking
there and it's lacking not just in the
whole system itself but in this person's
relation to him or herself their
consciousness for themselves mediated
through through these others so Hegel
goes on and said this is a solitary
person who stands over against the rest
and now notice this is that second
feature these constitute he says the
real authoritative universality of that
person for the single individual as such
is true only as a universal multiplicity
of single individuals and he talks here
in terms of an individual being cut off
from this multiplicity and we could
think about the absolute power in
actuality this person who occupies this
position or any other individual person
cut off from the social matrix in which
they they fit in they become almost
literally a nothing or they become a
bare individuality who is pure
contingency and will not be recognized
by the rest when this person is
is within this system he or she
dominates everything not not just in
terms of sheer power but in terms of
everybody looking to them as sort of the
the spokesperson for the community and
you know we have something like this
going on within modern liberal democracy
if you think about you know the
fundamental difference between the
legislative function and the executive
function you know this is the executive
function now in our very complex liberal
democracies much of this is within the
realm of the imaginary carried out
through through media and there are like
I said all these layers of faceless
individuals who execute the will of the
leader so Hegel goes on and he says this
content liberated from the negative
power controlling it is the chaos of
spiritual powers which in their
unfettered freedom become elemental
beings raging madly against one another
in a frenzy of destructive activity
their impotent self-consciousness is the
defenseless enclosed area of their
tumult so what would happen if you took
the Lord out of the picture all of these
would become elemental they would
descend into an elemental chaos of you
know really a Hobbesian war of all
against all and this is the sovereign
who stands in the place unquestioned and
unquestionable if they know what's good
for them and they want what's good for
society keeping the peace keeping the
order there's also that same sort of
play of the elemental chaos within this
person who occupies the highest spot
however there's nothing to you know
condition them to say to them remember
you're only human or hey maybe you
should you know not go to excess in in
what you're doing
you know again a problem that that goes
all the way back to Plato's discussions
of the tyrant is the tyrant truly free
so he goes on he says in this knowledge
of himself as the sum and substance of
all actual powers the sum and substance
of all these elemental potentially
antagonistic powers which could turn
against each other the Lord and Master
the world is and here's what Hegel says
the Titanic self-consciousness that
thinks of itself as being an actual
living God and now there there is sort
of the problem with you might call it
the you know hubris which is going to
arise out of the exercise the existence
of such a power being conscious of
oneself as being able to do anything to
the people down below provided they're
treated as individuals or perhaps as
classes what goes on after that he says
since he is only the formal self which
is unable to tame those powers his
activities and self enjoyment are
equally monstrous excesses so the lord
and master of the world the pure
actuality the pure power is in a certain
sense powerless against him or herself
their their consciousness for itself in
practical terms is a divided one
the Lord of the world becomes really
conscious of what he is that is the
universal power of the actual world in
the destructive power he exercises
against the self his subjects itself
which stands over against him for his
power is not the Union and harmony of
spirit in which persons would recognize
their own self-consciousness rather they
exist as persons on their own account
and exclude any continuity with others
from the rigid unyielding this of their
atomicity they exist therefore in a
merely negative relationship both to one
another and to him who is their bond of
connection or continuity in this
continuity he is the essence and the
content of their merely formal self but
a Content alien to them and a hostile
being which in reality deprives them of
that very thing which they regard as
their essential nature this is a
completely empty form of being for self
and again and the continuity of their
personality he destroys this very
personality itself legal personality
thus learns rather than it is without
any substance since the alien content
makes itself authoritative in it and
does so because that content is the
reality of such personality on the other
hand by indulging in this destructive
activity in this insubstantial arena the
lord of the world obtains for himself
the consciousness of his complete
supremacy
however this self is a mere laying waste
of everything and therefore merely
beside itself and is really the
abandonment of its own
self-consciousness
or graph 482 Hegel is going to develop
further this conflict between what he's
calling in this parent legal personality
that is the person as existing within
the the social realm of legal right or
legal condition vector stand and spirit
which he construes you know very
consistently as involving this mutual
recognition and that is what is lacking
here lacking even on the part of the
lord and master of the world and and
Hegel spell something out here that's
very interesting it connects up with
age-old reflections on tyranny and the
moral character of the tyrant or the
lack of self development and why that is
the case going all the way back to to
Plato and even really through Siddha
tease coming all the way into the
present you know by way of say Rousseau
and and Hobbes so Hegel tells us that
this Lord of the world becomes conscious
of what he is he has is his
self-consciousness his being for self
how he becomes conscious of who he is
the universal power of the actual world
the veer cleek the you know the real how
in the destructive power he exercises
now the destructive power he exercises
where against enemies outside of the
social sphere say those belonging to
another country or brigands or pirates
or criminals against his own subjects
the eagle has got his finger on
something really dark here which is that
those who are in power one you know we
often say power corrupts absolute power
corrupts absolutely this great phrase
coming from Lord Acton who is coming
later than
but this is a notion that has been
around for a long time before Acton gave
it its articulation why why does power
corrupt is it just well once you've got
power nobody's going to stand in your
way
Hegel is pointing at a dynamic involved
in power which is power is not only the
power to create but the power to destroy
the power to undo the power to pervert
to corrupt and you become more and more
fully aware of what that power is by
doing things that were you not in this
position would be considered irrevocably
bad transgressive crimes sins but
because the powerful have that there
they're able to do that and they not
only justify themselves in doing that or
perhaps don't even justify themselves
they get to know who they are in the
exercise of that power so Hinkle goes on
and he says this is a power he exercises
against the self of the subject the self
which stands over against them the rival
that he or she cannot endure now he says
the power that this person has is not
the Union and harmony of spirits again
this realm of mutual recognition that
we've been desiring and hoping to get to
eventually he says in which persons
would recognize their own
self-consciousness instead what we're
seeing is is everybody being alienated
from themselves he says they exist as
persons on their own account and exclude
any continuity from other with others
from the rigid unyielding this of their
atomicity so each of them is able to
have who they are their own little
projects their own little life goals
their own television to watch or Netflix
account their own you know self
description but they're not able to get
recognition from the other because why
would the other give them that
recognition when they're not giving
to the other each person becomes a sort
of sealed off existence against the
other perhaps they have a contingent set
of friendships and family relations but
those are also equally subject to this
and and above it all exists the Lord of
the world who can at any moment so bid
and take everything and this person over
here the other is not going to get your
back and make sure that that doesn't
happen
so Hegel says all these people are
existing in a merely negative
relationship both to one another and to
him who is their bond of connection or
continuity he says as this continuity he
is the essence and content to their
merely formal self but a content alien
to them he is over them he can exercise
destructive power against them even if
he doesn't do that they constantly have
to be you know concerned not to
transgress lest they wind up catching
his eye so to speak and so he goes on
and he says it would deprive them of the
very thing they regard as their
essential nature the completely empty
form of being for self and again is the
continuity of personality he destroyed
this very personality itself so he
destroys their essentiality by acting
against them what sort of concrete forms
could this take when you get you know
there's that that old famous song you
know I fought the law and the law won
how does the law win the law wins or the
the enforcer of the law wins by deciding
not just how to apply the law to you as
this defiant individual but by depriving
you of the very capacity to have that
being for self that that the the
executor has eventually they shut you up
they break you and you become what it is
that they say you are or even if you
remain defiant you're not able to get
your message out to anyone and there may
not be anybody else listening anyway
this is some some very almost prescient
stuff that Hegel is talking about if you
think about what happened to people in
the nineteenth twentieth and it's still
happening to people in the 21st century
through the exercise of arbitrary let's
call it state or in some cases corporate
power by individuals who are totally
unaccountable so Hegel goes on and he
says legal personality thus learns it is
without any substance the alien content
makes it authoritative in it and does so
because that content is the reality of
such personality so what was you know
what was supposed to be guaranteed to us
by legal personality you know legal
right not this but Hegel is pointing
something out here that the law cannot
stand in the way of the one who is
trying to execute the law this whole
system of legal right is rather
precarious then toward the end he also
talks about what is going on within the
consciousness of the Lord of the world
he says on the other hand by indulging
in this destructive activity in this
insubstantial arena the lord of the
world obtains for himself the
consciousness of his complete supremacy
that is by you know exercising this you
know destructive power he could say I'm
better than you I am the law I am the
one who's in charge but notice the last
sentence this is that this self is a
mere laying waste of everything and
thereby merely beside itself and is
really the abandonment of its own
self-consciousness itself
winds up being empty unsatisfying does
not provide the recognition that the
lord of the world is like everybody else
seeking and they wind up although able
to exercise power just as in
as strange as alienated as everyone else
such that is the constitution of that
aspect in which self-consciousness quat
absolute being is actual but the
consciousness that is driven back into
itself from this actuality Ponder's this
it's in essential nature earlier we saw
the stoical independence of pure thought
past your skepticism and find its truth
in the unhappy consciousness the truth
about what constitutes its own true
being if this knowledge appeared then
merely is the one-sided view of
consciousness as consciousness here the
actual truth of that view has become
apparent this truth consists in the fact
that this universally acknowledged
authority of self consciousness is the
reality from which it is alienated this
acknowledgment of its authority of the
universal actuality of the self but this
actuality is directly the perversion of
the self as well it is the loss of its
essence the actuality of the self that
did not exist in the ethical world has
been won by its return into the person
what in the former was harmoniously one
now merges in a developed form but has
alienated from itself
Hegel's finishes with paragraph 483 this
entire first section of spirit getting
us ready to move into the next by
bringing to the fore this concept of
alienation or estrangement which we're
going to discuss in great great detail
so I don't need to talk about it quite
here and this is not something that is
radically new because as we saw there is
a parallelism that he's been playing
with in what's going on in legal
condition or legal right this this new
way of working things out in terms of
ethical consciousness and what was going
on earlier in the self consciousness
section you know after the master-slave
dialectic we have this stoicism then
skepticism non the unhappy consciousness
I don't know I don't think I need to go
into any great detail anymore because we
discussed all of that in the previous
paragraph and in those sections
originally but suffice it to say Hegel
sees there being a kind of necessary
dialectic of development running along
these and culminating in a alienation of
the individual from in this case the the
object of worship or devotion which is
seen as being the absolute from which
they are separated not really realizing
that they themselves are projecting that
out there so something similar is
happening in the dialectic that we've
just looked at in this new shape of
consciousness beginning with the legal
person which seems like a great starting
point but that eventually leads into
something like the confusion of
skepticism which then gets dealt with in
terms of property which then seems
completely contingent and we see the
requirement of the Lord of the world
over everybody else the Lord of the
world upon whom there are no checks and
balances not only from those below him
or her but even within him or her and so
the person becomes a subject a legal
subject to the
of the world and so Hagel says you know
this is the constitution of that aspect
in which self-consciousness quoi
absolute being is actual but the
consciousness that is driven back into
itself from this actuality Ponder's this
it's in essential nature living what
Hegel saying here is living within a
regime in which like in the unhappy
consciousness you try all these
different ways to sort of you know make
it work to reconnect yourself to the
Lord what is the absolute the lord of
the world what is essential trying all
those those things all of them fail none
of them give you what you're actually
looking for but they do yield the truth
that you are alienated from not only
your neighbor not only the the person
who's in charge but yourself you are
alienated consciousness and he says we
saw the stoic independence of pure
thought pass through skepticism find its
truth in happy consciousness the truth
about what constitutes its own being and
here he says that was in terms of the
one-sided view of consciousness as
consciousness
now the actual truth of that view has
become apparent what is that truth he
says this truth consists in the fact
that this universally acknowledged
authority of self consciousness is the
reality from which it is alienated this
recognition or acknowledgement of its
authority is the universal actuality of
the self this is what we would want to
be connected to
but this actuality is also he says the
perversion of the self as well it is the
loss of its essence so what's the
culmination the actuality in itself that
did not exist in the ethical world has
been won by its return into the person
the individual what what in the former
was harmoniously one now emerges in a
developed form which is good but is
alienated from itself so all of this has
been this long process I mean a lot of
other things have been going on along
the way very important development
but one of the outcomes one of the key
developments in this is of now having
individuals who are not the lord of the
world but rather individuals who are now
saying what what the hell am i I'm not
sure anymore I have to figure out where
I exist how I make sense within the
social order who who am i what am I what
will I make myself and that is what
we're going to start discussing in this
next great section of the work this
portion of spirit that we call culture